[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique sur
france 3 bourgogne occupations
d'université barricades débat des
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
les rues
une france paralysée par les mouvements
sociaux la plus grande grève générale de
son histoire il ya 50 ans un vent de
contestation souffle est sûre notre pays
le mouvement de mai 68 à les bousculer
la france pendant plusieurs semaines
cette lutte contre la société
traditionnelle et l'autorité impulsée
par les étudiants et les ouvriers a
engendré un changement radical de
société alors 50 ans après quel héritage
à laisser mai 68 l'esprit de mai 68 est
il toujours présent dans les universités
et dans notre société
les mouvements sociaux d'aujourd'hui
peuvent-ils converger et devenir à
nouveau mai 68 on en débat ce matin avec
mes invités jean vigreux bonjour bonjour
vous êtes professeur d'histoire à
l'université de bourgogne franche comté
on aura votre regard d'historien mais
aussi de professeurs d'université
d'aujourd'hui dans cette émission marcel
petit bonjour bonjour vous êtes
aujourd'hui bourguignons mais vous étiez
étudiant à nanterre en 1968 tout à fait
vous avez connu les événements bien
avant le mois de mai d'ailleurs du côté
de nanterre avec quelques personnalités
célèbres dont nous reparlerons sans
doute sébastien mirek bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le référent de la république
en marche en côte d'or avec vous on fera
aussi le lien avec les débats
d'aujourd'hui qui agitent la société et
qui questionne la politique d' emmanuel
macron bourg noir clair bonjour je vous
êtes vice président de l'unef bourgogne
on regardera comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui dans les universités puis on
entendra aussi votre regard d'étudiants
de 2018 sur ce mouvement de mai 68 merci
à tous les quatre d'avoir accepté de
participer à cette émission en direct ce
dimanche vous qui nous regarde et vous
en avez l'habitude vous pouvez commenter
cette émission sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne
avant de confronter les regards des uns
et des autres et les points de vue
retour sur ce printemps 1968 chez nous à
dijon avec michel gillot et christophe
gaillard
pour l'instant les bars 68
c'est le printemps mais sur le campus
dijonnais à quoi sert le printemps si
les étudiants ne peuvent pas rendre
visite aux étudiantes et réciproque
le sel départ de la sphère la libre
circulation dans les cités
universitaires
une liberté qui a été revendiquée très
vite on a occupé pendant quinze jours
trois semaines et pavillons en
alternance la nuit va bien deux filles à
jour n'est pas un garçon et on obtenu
rapidement relativement rapidement la
liberté totale de cette mutation le 3
mai après l'intervention des crs à la
sorbonne ya un appel qui est fait donc
c'est jacques sauvageau qui était ancien
dijonnais ancien président de la corpo
de lettres qui assure la présidence de
l'unef sur la violence et appelle à un
soutien généralisé et le voir à la grève
générale peu de temps après parce que
c'était la première fois depuis 12 131
que les policiers rentrée sur un campus
donc c'est insupportable les profs
dijonnais démarre aussi vite que les
étudiants depuis plusieurs années déjà
il ne supporte plus le mandarinat et le
fonctionnement très hiérarchique de
l'université bientôt le rideau se lève
sur le troisième acteur du mai 68
dijonnais et pas des moindres le monde
du travail industrie services publics
grands magasins au plus fort du
mouvement entre le 20 et le 25 mai
quarante mille personnes sont en grève
6 mai 9 mai 11 mai 13 mai les manifs
s'enchaînent certaines sont à contre
courant à dijon lentilles mai 68 donne
de la voix est parfois plus les
étudiants de droite et d'extrême droite
ont un allié de poids le sac service
d'action civique une officine gaulliste
assez musclé est bien implanté le sac
régné en maître à la mairie
quand même pas l'oublier ou après robert
poujade la diriger personnellement mais
le sac était omniprésent pour autant à
dijon les affrontements furent rares et
les forces de police plutôt discrète
cinquante ans plus tard ce qui tient le
haut du pavé dans la mémoire des acteurs
du mai 68 étudiants c'est plutôt le
souvenir d'un émerveillement le souvenir
d'un émerveillement jean vigreux c'était
ça aussi mai 68
oui ça participe à ça ce sont des
rencontres inattendues
c'est la libération de la parole déjà
c'est important d'aucuns vont prendre
pour la première fois la parole en
assemblée générale on invente le moa
j'ai véritablement on a vu la dent dans
les photographies les amphithéâtres et
les revendications des étudiants mais
aussi la rencontre avec les ouvriers
puisque c'est ce qui caractérise ces
huit semaines qui ébranlèrent la france
vraiment c'est un temps long qui font
prendre rencontre des étudiants
rencontre des ouvriers des salariés on a
évoqué aussi le rôle des enseignants du
supérieur les jeunes assistants qui ont
un rôle important puisque la fac
commence à se démocratiser où on a le
devoir des centaines de milliers
d'adhérents de c'est à dire en étudiant
pendant qu'ils arrivent excusez moi on
passe à peu près 400 mille cinq cent
mille étudiants en france donc il faut
encadrer tout ça pour des td et les
jeunes assistants un rôle ont un rôle
important
c'est un des premiers aspects sur cet
émerveillement mais en même temps il
faut le regarder par rapport à un jeux
d'échelle
vous avez ici la province la bourgogne
si on a dit c'est le 4 mai que ça débute
puisqu'il faut être solidaire avec les
étudiants parisiens c'est le fameux
libérez nos camarades qui lance
véritablement le mouvement cette
solidarité mais c'est un aller retour
paris province et puis il faut le
regarder à une échelle beaucoup plus
globale internationale c'est les
contestations de la guerre du vietnam
c'est l'assassinât de martin luther king
c'est ce qui se passe en tchécoslovaquie
c'est ce qui se passe aussi dans lé sud
il ya un mai 68 au sénégal au même
moment donc il faut le regarder dans des
contestations des carcans anciens de
l'ordre ancien qui qui qui est en route
face à l'ordre bipolaire la guerre
froide c'est le petit vous en mars 1968
on monte un petit peu en arrière
revivez les événements du côté à de
l'université à nanterre qu'est-ce qui se
passe et qu'est ce qui motive finalement
7 ce début de lutte on va dire alors
tout au départ c'était une revendication
un peu stupide talent et d'avoir une
mixité sur le on a entendu c'était la
même année là c'était un peu étrange
et puis il ya eu un bouillonnement à
meylan justement de deux classes de
choses de gens qui allaient voir
d'étudiants qui allait voir les
travailleurs cas les eaux de calais osé
signer et puis surtout une discussion
comme on dira tout azimut
sur quel avenir quelque chose
où va-t-on et ces symptômes qui a le
plus d'importance arrive bien sûr la
grève générale une millions de grévistes
c'est impressionnant et une france qui
était complètement paralysé vous parlez
comme jean vigreux de ces échanges qui
avait entre étudiants et ouvriers
aujourd'hui ça paraît très loin je sais
pas si noir car nous dira qu'il y en a
encore mais c'était la spécificité aussi
de mai 68 et c'est ce qui a permis
finalement que ce mouvement prenne de
l'ampleur selon vous tout à fait
peut-être qu'à l'époque la plupart des
étudiants organisée était d'obédience
marxiste pour pour comprendre un peu oui
donc le prolétariat était un mythe et
sorte de tous choisi le tennis est à
dire que vous étudiants parlé avec un
ouvrier c'était un truc génial jean piat
tout à fait alors qu'aujourd'hui les
étudiants rêvent peut-être d'être
ingénieur médecin que sais-je nommant
tout à fait vous vous aviez envie
d'échanger avec les ouvriers pourquoi
c'était un ami et bien parce que c'était
une idéologie qui était très implanté
dans le milieu étudiant sur la
révolution quand même et la révolution
du point de vue commun d historique
on est très on avait l'impression d'être
en 1905
c'était accepter une répétition générale
d'une révolution à venir
la suite nous montra que non mais bon il
ya eu la répétition et puis voilà après
ces quelques semaines de mobilisation
tout s'est arrêté à bras sans doute nous
noir clair quand vous
ecoutez-le étudiant de mai 68 est ce que
vous vous dites c'était un autre monde
est ce que vous vous dites on pourrait
avoir les mêmes revendications les mêmes
ambitions pour cette société il ya des
similitudes certaine entre mai 68 et les
mobilisations qui a actuellement
hélas même la société enfin l'avant mai
68 et la société actuelle bien que la
société ait vraiment évolué il ya quand
même de grosses similitudes notamment
dans le pouvoir politique et dans la
volonté politique
là on a entendu le comment dire
l'élément déclencheur à nanterre mais il
ya enfin un mai 68 comme le disait jean
vigreux tout à l'heure c'est vraiment un
un ensemble de problématiques qui ont
qui ont amorcé les révoltes et notamment
une qui est la sélection à l'entrée de
l'université déjà en mai 68 on en
parlait en 67 68 parce que il ya eu un
boom démographique
on est passé de 200 à 500 mille
étudiants extrêmement rapidement
actuellement on connaît aussi ce genre
de problématique avec un nombre
d'étudiants croissant rentrée 2018 on
aura jusqu'à quarante mille étudiants
qui vont qui vont de 40 mille nouveaux
étudiants à l'entrée de l'université est
déjà à l'époque le gouvernement parlait
de sélection scolaire actuellement on
parle en gare de sélection sup et par
course et cette sélection c'est
simplement une assignation enfin ça peut
être vu et c'est simplement une
assignation à résidence
c'est dire à quelqu'un parce qu'ils
habitent un tel endroit qu'il a moins de
chances de réussir que quelqu'un d'autre
et c'est totalement insupportable et ça
se ressent effectivement chez les
étudiants et dans les mobilisations
étudiantes en ce moment et depuis depuis
le début de l'année sébastien miracle
vous représentez cette nouvelle
génération qui a suivi emmanuel macron
depuis avant même son élection à la
présidence de la république
comment vous vous regardez cette période
et vous est ce que vous vous pensez que
l
nous apporte des choses pour aujourd'hui
alors je vais déjà répondre en premier
sur la sélection à l'universel si on y
va on va y revenir je pense mais je
voudrais que les choses soient claires
on parle de d'orientation de réussite
des étudiants c'est le plan aux heureux
et donc ce plan étudiants on est là pour
la réussite des étudiants et le
gouvernement en tout cas c'est ce qui a
été dit c'est ce qui sera fait donc
l'orientation de ses étudiants dans les
bonnes filières
il ya eu des postes qui sont
supplémentaires qui ont été créés cette
année il ya dix-neuf mille postes ont
été créés c'est ce plan a mis fin au
tirage au sort qui était une injustice
et donc on veut une université plus
humaine donc ça c'est vraiment
l'objectif
et puis de la réussite il faut des
parcours personnalisés donc voilà et
puis s'intéressait aux étudiants j'ai
été étudiant
donc voilà après pour la similitude mai
68 à mai 68
mai 68 je ne vais pas connu à titre
personnel ni à titre familial parce que
ma famille arrivée en france après mai
68 par contre j'ai au niveau de
l'histoire écouté et entendu les les
personnes qui en parlent qu'ils ont vécu
à la fois au niveau local au niveau
national est ce qu'il ya une similitude
par rapport à au mouvement actuel il ya
une chose qu'on peut remarquer c'est que
à l'époque mai 68 le la contestation
venait des étudiants vous l'avait bien
dit auparavant partaient des étudiants
et c'était pas d un mouvement qui était
politisé initialement avec les étudiants
avaient des idées mais alors c'est le
dynamisme était très présent donc c'est
une forme de politisation calmer le
mouvement était tenu quand même par les
étudiants au départ et puis après il ya
eu les ouvriers les syndicats qui ont
qui ont pris les choses les choses
actuellement on n'est pas du tout dans
ce contexte là il ya un petit
groupe d'étudiants qui ont contesté le
plan étudiant mais en tout cas on n'est
pas dans une hes que la plus grande
différence ça n'est pas que la culture a
changé et là j'allais dire la chance du
gouvernement et des manuels macron
aujourd'hui c'est pas que il n'ya plus
cette culture de la lutte cette culture
du combat social
on voit bien qu'on peine par moments à
rassembler dans les rues les syndicats
les mouvements de gauche ont du mal à
rassembler et du coup il ya une fenêtre
de tir j'allais dire pour emmanuel
macron de faire passer des réformes
malgré une contestation qui n'arrive pas
à mobiliser le mouvement politique des
manuels maquereau en marche dont je suis
le référent en côte d'or est un
mouvement ouvert on est à la fois de
gauche à la fin de droite et on n'a pas
ces clivages là et donc on est vraiment
dans une réflexion d'ouverture et c'est
ce qu'il a fait notre adn c'est ce qui
fait notre adn dans marche d'hier un
gouvernement pour faire passer des
réformes il faut que la contestation
soit assez limité aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'impression parle beaucoup de la
convergence des luttes on y reviendra
on a vu les manifestations du 1er mai il
ya du monde les syndicats sont même pas
capables de se mettre ensemble pour
manifester donc on voit bien qu'il ya
une différence
alors la méthode du gouvernement reste
la même c'est la concertation et chaque
réforme qui ont été travaillés dans la
première sur la moralisation de la vie
politique il ya de la concertation il ya
de la concertation il ya un point
important aussi c'est les choses qui ont
été dit pendant le programme
présidentiel sont faites on l'a dit on
le fait c'est pour ça que sa peine à
mobiliser
marcel petit aujourd'hui cette culture
de la lutte que vous vous avez connu
elle n'existe plus elle existe moins
géré avec cette culture de la lutte y
avait aussi un désir énorme de
libéralisation de la société on
étouffait ce gaullisme un petit peu et
donc ça c'est la conjonction des deux
qui ont fait qu'il ya eu cette ouverture
fabuleuse cette envie de changement et
on était la génération gaulliste j'ai
connu que de gaulle de 10 ans à 20 ans
oh c'était quand même un quart temps par
exemple il y avait loué rtf était
vraiment
comment dire mais je vais bien muselé
parce que mes étés c1 par le pouvoir en
place
voilà c'était vraiment la voix de son
maître voilà et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
les formes sont protéiformes son
repreneur automobilisme - aujourd'hui
qui elle n'arrive plus à a créé un
mouvement je pense que les amis ou noir
clair il aimerait bien mobiliser plus il
faut être relatifs parce que je me
rappelle que le monde titrait avant 68
la france s'ennuie et ils se sont
trompés quand même lourdement
enfin là dessus sur l'éditorial devient
son côté qui est qu un classique sur la
france s'ennuie je suis d'accord c'est
le titre mais en même temps il pointait
à l'intérieur de son éditorial tous les
dysfonctionnements de la société
c'est-à-dire les enjeux d'une croissance
très forte mais qui était pas partager
il y avait des travailleurs pauvres les
os étaient mal payés c'est à dire qu'il
y avait aussi tout un enjeu de
revendications sociales qu'il ne fallait
pas perdre de vue
et là vous voyez les similitudes il y en
a il y en a si les inégalités
croissantes
c'est à dire en fin de compte d'un côté
une france entre guillemets des riches
et et et le reste et d'un autre côté
aussi jamais perdre de vue ce qui
commençait à apparaître
67 avec les ordonnances on a changé la
sécurité sociale a créé la haine pe et
celui qui était appelé monsieur chômage
à l'époque c'était jacques chirac parce
qu'on commençait à voir poindre le début
chômage ça rien à voir avec aujourd'hui
puisque aujourd'hui on est dans un
chômage de masse etc
mais il y avait déjà cessé ces enjeux là
en revanche oui ce qui a changé c'est la
composition de la société c puis la même
on allait en avoir 3 milliards mobilisés
alors on affirme obligés différemment
n'oubliez pas qu'en 68 ce qui fait le
catalyseur de la mobilisation c'est que
vous avez encore un parti communiste à
300 mille adhérents qui est un cinquième
de l'électorat en france qui a un enjeu
aussi particulier de comment est revenu
le général de gaulle au pouvoir en 1958
sur la sortie de la guerre d'algérie il
ya tout ça aussi qui marquent la société
dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui on n'a
peut-être plus à ça c'est effectivement
mais les syndicats au début ils sont pas
forcément unis force ouvrière ses vingt
ans après la scission sedif il se
retrouvait que la cgt biais entre temps
il ya eu un accord en 66 y avait été cgt
il ya un syndicat qui a un rôle
fondamental et qu'on oublie souvent
c'est la fin
parce qu'elle va du primaire au
supérieur que oui elle existe plus et il
a eu ce rôle de d'être l'interface entre
les étudiants les ouvriers et de ramener
et faux dans dans le giron aussi pour ça
qu'il ya eu cette unité syndicale
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement un peu
plus difficile mais ça participe aussi
d'une volonté est ce que il ya cette
volonté de le faire ou pas loup noir
clair j'entendais marcel petit il ya un
instant dire on étouffait sous le
gaullisme vavoua l'unef vous étouffez
pas encore sur le maquereau nice mais il
est là que depuis un an il est plus
qu'un an mais c'est tout un système qui
est remis en cause le système était déjà
remis en cause en 68 il ya eu un
basculement un gros basculement et et
depuis il ya ya ya beaucoup de choses
pour en bon alors moi je fais l'unef
donc en ce moment l'actualité fait que
je vais beaucoup parlé de la sélection à
l'université laval élections à
l'université cheval de bataille parce
que pas que c'est aussi la défense des
étudiants en général et l'information
des étudiants mais cette sélection
universités elle a voulu être instaurée
par le pouvoir politique en place
en 67 68 elle est revenue sur la table
en 86 avec le projet de loi devaquet qui
a été refusé par part par les étudiants
à l'époque et depuis 2007 on aperçoit
une décentralisation croissante des
universités avec du pouvoir qui est
redonnée aux universités une division un
petit peu enfin ce qui induit une
division des universités entre elles
puisque les étudiants n'ont pas les
mêmes problématiques sur chaque
université vous avez peur qui
habituellement est actuellement en 2018
et bien la sélection est remise sur la
table
donc c'est pas con quand vous parliez
d'étouffer sous ma chronique mais en
fait c'est étouffer sur des volontés
sous des volontés et depuis des dizaines
d'années d'instaurer des règles que
peut-être les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne
souhaite pas non plus et il souhaite
pouvoir s'émanciper pouvoir intégrer
université ouverte à toutes et à tous et
c'est ce qui risque de ne plus pouvoir
se passer à partir de
de la rentrée 2011 j'ai posé une
question marcel petit mais peut-être que
tout le monde a envie de réagir
est ce que quand j'essaye d'expliquer
qu'on n'arrivait plus à mobiliser
aujourd'hui autant qu'en mai 68 que le
monde avait quand même un peu évolué et
jean vigreux nous rappeler que les
choses ont changé il ya un monde qui a
disparu quand vous regardez quelqu'un
que vous avez connu à nanterre qui
s'appelle daniel cohn bendit ee daniel
cohn bendit en 1968 était le leader ou
l'un des leaders de avec jean de la
contestation
aujourd'hui daniel cohn bendit quand il
appelle à voter emmanuel macron et qui
soutient la politique d' emmanuel macron
qu'est ce que vous vous dites vous
marcel petit qu'il l'avait bien connu
je me dis que la lutte des classes et la
lutte des castes traverse aussi les
organisations politiques
on n'avait pas tous les mêmes objectifs
je me rappelle que cohn bendit avait dit
vous générez tous ministre et il y en a
qu'un qui a fini un peu c'est lui j'ai
connu beaucoup de camarades qui sont
cons fait partie de l'ailé qui font
partie de l'élite
j'ai bien que du mélenchon par exemple
travail voilà ce jour dans la rue quand
même un peu willy est toujours dans la
prière il a quand même été ministre ou
si oui non non non tout le monde oublie
un peu sa voix et mais je pense que ce
qui a fédéré fondamentalement les
mouvements c'est la guerre du vietnam
tout le monde était anti guerre tout le
monde était pour us go home et ça ça
vraiment fédérer internationalement tous
les mouvements de jeunesse
je reviens sur daniel cohn bendit une
seconde pour savoir ce que vous lui
diriez si vous le croisiez demain pour
qu'il avait connu à l'époque
moi j'ai pas j'ai aucune ong c'est ça me
fait un peu rigoler de voir selon marche
là a les yeux qui a commencé à l'extrême
gauche et qui est finie comment dire qui
rêve d'être président de l'union
européenne je le pense oui je pense
peut-être que les amis de sébastien
direct pourront l'aider
sébastien mirek ça montre aussi que les
choses ont évolué et que le monde a
changé le monde a changé mais peut-être
pas tant que ça quand on voit fsu daniel
cohn bendit
on peut on peut parler de ce personnage
on a eu plein d'autres qui sont qui sont
venus à en marge et qui continueront à
venir et qui montre bien cette ouverture
et ces discussions la plus ouverte
possible avec cette concertation
citoyenne sur le plan étudiant je dis
juste deux mots sur un effectif c'est le
premier gouvernement emmanuel macron qui
investit autant 1 milliards sur le
quinquennat
donc ça veut bien dire que c'est une
priorité une des priorités pour
développer pour aider pour faire des
parcours spécialisés plus adapté et
universités les plus plus humaine
c'est pas un milliard qu'il faut c'est
pas un milliard sur cinq ans c'est 1,5 à
2 milliards par an pour qu'il faudrait
pour que l'université puisse être
ouverte à tous ses atours à vous dire
qu'à pas l'âge et à voir mais l'argent
l'éducation et l'enseignement supérieur
n'est pas un coup c'est un
investissement sur le long terme sur
l'avenir la france a su s'endetter pour
beaucoup de choses elle peut très bien
s'en était de 2 milliards par an pour
rien réinjecter de l'argent dans
l'enseignement supérieur afin d'avoir
cette université française que l'on
connaît depuis tant d'années qui reste
ouvert à toutes et à tous plutôt que la
transformer dans certains cas peut être
en grande école avec une sélection à
l'entrée des universités extrêmement
élitiste des universités qui elles vont
être ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
d'université poubelle c'est pas comme ça
qu'on oriente les étudiants ou les
experts réagir à peine cinq minutes
d'attention deux choses d'abord sur
compte bendit il y avait quand même des
choses à expliquer si l'évolution d'un
personnage est bon il est marié
représentatif de l'ensemble de cette
génération
à un moment donné il ya aussi des enjeux
particuliers personnel de gaulle évoqué
la vieillesse est un naufrage peut-être
on pourrait revenir là dessus mais au
delà au delà de ça moi ce qui ce qui
m'intéresse c'est aujourd'hui ici
investissement mais comme l'a rappelé le
dirigeant de l'ugt 9
c'est beaucoup plus qu'il faudrait et la
logique de l'autonomie des universités
nous amis quand même en concurrence et
c'est ça qui est paradoxal c'est à dire
que depuis de nombreuses années il
manque des postes on peut pas accueillir
tout le monde
et qu'est ce que l'on veut est-ce qu'à
l'université elle ne va être réservé
qu'à certains et c'est ça la grande la
grande peur aujourd'hui qu'on non
seulement les étudiants mais aussi les
enseignants et qu'il ne
il faudrait qu'on ait des td beaucoup
plus beaucoup moins nombreux et qu'on
est véritablement un investissement sur
le long terme c'est à dire former la
jeunesse de demain et c'est ça le
réalisation d'enseignement supérieur
marcel petit on a l'impression que les
étudiants ne sont pas non plus dans la
même dynamique qu'à l'époque à l'époque
où on avait l'impression d'un regard
plus optimiste plus positifs en tous les
cas sur l'avenir aujourd'hui les
étudiants voient clairement qu'ils ont
peur de l'avenir
c'est vrai mais 68 était joyeuse aussi
je crois qu'on a oublié ça il me semble
que là j'ai plus une jeunesse il ya déjà
naissent aujourd'hui et des jeunes est
ce qu est une ceux qui ne se croisent
plus qu'ils ne se parlent plus qu'ils
ont des intérêts très différent et je
pense aussi qu'il faudrait penser qu'on
a un front national à 20% plus ou plus
et que ça change fondamentalement la
donne fondamentalement et que cette
massification étudiante existe quand
même compliqué à gérer
alors je vais vous proposer de regarder
des extraits d'un sondage viavoice qui
ont été publiées par le quotidien
libération
cinquante ans après les événements 70 %
des français interrogés jugent
positivement l'héritage de mai 68 et son
impact sur la société et puis regardez
aussi comment les français voient mai 68
aujourd'hui pour 61% c'est la
convergence étudiants ouvriers et pour
d'autres c'est plus l'un ou l'autre vous
le voyez sur ce sondage alors j'aimerais
qu'on ça nous amène à la question de la
convergence des luttes parce qu'on voit
bien quand même que pour les français
encore aujourd'hui c'est la convergence
des mouvements étudiants et ouvriers qui
ont fait la particularité de mai 68
aujourd'hui on est loin de ça gens
vivront alors c'est la convergence des
luttes il ya ouvriers étudiants y avait
aussi les salariés il faut bien voir
aussi le changement de la société c'est
l'entrée des femmes dans le monde du
travail
c'est ça aussi qui est important en 68
c'est la jeunesse du baby boom
on les retrouve à allah lusine les
jeunes c'est l'irruption aussi la figure
de l'immigré du travailleur immigré que
pendant longtemps on voyait pas bien on
le voit apparaître en 68 donc il ya tous
ces enjeux qu'il faut pas perdre de vue
mais dans votre sondage qui est quand
même toujours un
pression' ans c'est à dire on veut
essayer de picorer sur 68 mai 68 c'est
un blog ça s'inscrit dans dans quelque
chose de global et on va nous présenter
on va tirer abbayas que capote 14% les
travailleurs non c'est la grande plaque
grandes grèves ouvrières plus importante
que celle que du front populaire
alors oui l'idée de la convergence des
buts mais cela vient aussi de peut-être
de la structuration du monde syndical
aujourd'hui en france qui est ultra
divisé et peut-être qu'il faudrait
arriver à dépasser ces divisions pour
aller vers cette convergence des luttes
mais là c'est une autre histoire
1 c elle doit se construire il n'y a pas
de modèle historique en tant que tel
c'est ce qu'a appris peut-être 68 c'est
qu'on n'a pas un modèle qui se répète il
faut l'inventer il et de son présent il
est de son moment ça vous surprend
c'est ce regard des français sur mes
soixante un petit peu je crois qu on
oublie aussi la disparition du
prolétariat les l'industrie les usines
ne sont plus autant comment dire
présente qu'à cette époque là et ça ça
change beaucoup la vie même s'il existe
un nombre encore important d'où vient le
problème cccc voilà c'est qu'elle
remarque on en a et puis surtout ce qui
encadrait ce monde ouvrier un parti
communiste très fort une série très très
forte
il ya 16 ans il ya ces enjeux là une
tradition ouvrière o'shea il voulait
revenir sur cette convergence est ce
rapport à mai 68 on en revient toujours
à l'avant c'est aussi le but de
l'émission de comparer les mouvements
actuels au mouvement de mai 68 mais
comme le disait jean vigreux extrêmement
bien c'est que on ne bâtit pas
l'histoire en répétant dans essayant de
se rapprocher au mieux de d'un mouvement
qui a réussi à son époque les étudiants
ils ont changé aussi
il y a des similitudes à l'heure
actuelle avec mai 68 il est un contexte
global qui peut comporter également des
similitudes mais mais pas que et pour le
reste l'avenir nous dira merci à tous
d'avoir accepté de participer à cette
émission en direct merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi jean vigreux je cite vos
ouvrages qui viennent de paraître
croissance et contestations 1958 1980
aux éditions du seuil et mai 68 en
bourgogne aux éditions universitaires de
dijon merci
tous merci bong lens
[Musique]